[Música]
eu gostaria de convidar vocês para fazer
um exercício de imaginação comigo
prometo que não vai ser difícil imagine
pra mim uma sala de aula
simples e aposto que a maioria das salas
de aula que vocês imaginaram são aquelas
com parede de tijolo a carteira de
madeira com estrutura de aço
imagine pra mim agora 50 alunos 50
crianças dentro desta sala de aula
por favor mas também barulho que elas
estão fazendo e eu sentar na frente na
posição do professor e antes de começar
a sua aula você vai chegar para essas
crianças e falou o seguinte eu quero que
12 de vocês se levantem e vai embora da
sala e não volta porque o mais provável
é que vocês 12 não conseguir terminar o
ensino fundamental vão abandonar a
repetir tanto vocês vão lá fora da idade
adequada pra aqui dentro então não perca
tempo de vocês e não é isso que tem
valor pra gente porque ficaram você vai
falar o seguinte
agora eu quero que se levantem e faz a
mesma coisa pode agora você se formaram
no ensino fundamental mas o mais
provável é que vocês 10 não consigam
terminar o ensino médio também vão
repetir muito ouvir com deficiência
matemática português vão conseguir
acompanhar não podem ir embora mas que
tem valor pra gente
agora se tem na sua sala de aula um
pouco mais da metade dos alunos
eles conseguiram terminar o ensino médio
eu sei que fala mas ainda não é isso que
eu quero que só nove fiquem aqui o resto
todo mundo pode ir embora também tem na
área ensino médio vai procurar uma
ocupação que só vocês vão conseguir ter
acesso ao ensino superior
só esses novos vão conseguir com os 9 em
salas e fala agora sim vocês vão
conseguir ter acesso a uma universidade
mas ainda quero que metade pega quatro
vai embora
vocês vão invadindo vocês vão conseguir
terminar
o ensino superior mas agora os cinco
estão aqui você 5 você 55 têm valor
então vamos começar na sala cruel né
exercício de imaginação mas infelizmente
o que acontece hoje no brasil esse funil
da sala de aula a esses dados
estatísticos todos saíram dos nossos
institutos de pesquisa e hoje uma
criança que está ali no ensino
fundamental são essas estatísticas que
ela vê se a gente não mudar a educação
até lá
aí acho que ainda falta um ponto pra
comentar
aquele 5 que conseguiram sobreviver a
esse funil dos 50 quando chegarem no
mercado as empresas vão falar e não em
cima de você está ultrapassado
mas que serve pra gente hoje ainda essas
competências não sabem mexer com as
tecnologias que a gente quer
então e daqui a pouco vão achar uma
máquina que vai fazer você faz melhor e
mais barato
a educação ela está falhando enormemente
em conseguir alcançar todos nós
independentemente de onde no frio você
tá se você parou no ensino fundamental
se você sobreviveu foi até o ensino
superior ou se você não conseguiu ter
acesso a uma sala de aula
a educação está falando é novamente
conseguir alcançar todos nós que ela
deveria atender o senhor que robson que
é um educador e tem as suas palestras do
ted entre as mais vistas do mundo ele
falou uma vez que a educação é um
precisa passar por uma reforma precisa
passar por uma revolução e de forma a
gente entende né
a gente vai reformar nossa saúde a nossa
casa a gente vai lá consertar um buraco
mexe com os móveis lugar com certo
telhados em casa a gente precisa na
verdade refazer toda base revolução não
passa por essa melhoria contínua
evolução seria a gente entender essa
casa patente atendendo que eu preciso
hoje qualquer função ela reforma é muito
sobre o que eu como revolução é sobre
quem e por que a gente é aprofundar um
pouco nesses dois pontos
eu gostaria de viajar com vocês agora
para conhecer dois casos dois casos que
vieram em momentos que eu tive um dos
maiores aprendizados assim na minha vida
pode ser
o primeiro caso nosso ele é o seguinte
se a gente quer entender um pouco do
qual é o melhor modelo melhor formato de
educação
vamos atrás dos melhores né então a
nossa primeira parada na finlândia que
tem um dos melhores formatos de educação
do mundo
se os índices de ensino de matemática
línguas ciências estão sempre entre os
melhores e quando estive lá eu pude
conhecer algumas universidades centros
de pesquisa inovação instituições de
ensino centros criativos colaborativos
de aprendizado mas o caso eu vou contar
na verdade não veio de nenhum desses
locais formais de educação numa noite a
gente estava jantando na casa de um
casal finlandês e tava lá o filho deles
10 12 anos ea gente comentando sobre o
modelo formato de educação da finlândia
sobre as inovações que têm em relação ao
brasil pegando muita perspectiva dos
finlandeses e afinal de contas a gente
está falando de educação de uma criança
e inevitável a gente outra criança
perguntou e aí ea escola você gosta da
escola e o filho do casal olhou pra
gente falou não é chato não é chato
meninos está no melhor formato de
educação do mundo e acha chato mas eu
também não sei qual é a nossa
expectativa é que o livro fosse olhar e
falar nossa amo esse lugar por favor me
largar me deixa aqui pra sempre
não sei se é isso que a gente esperava e
método a conversa acabou assim como
risada meio constrangedora com os nossos
anfitriões e de fato pra gente isso da
educação
a finlândia tem formato ideal porque a
escola ela tem um formato para
incentivar a autonomia e independência
das crianças
as disciplinas têm o formato já as
crianças trabalharem com projetos e
pensarem de forma multidisciplinar
a sala de aula tem o formato para
colaboração a carteira tem o formato o
formato talvez entretanto formato assim
na educação também não conseguiu
alcançar esse menino que estava o nosso
jantar
agora o nosso segundo caso a gente vai
para o outro lado do mundo
a gente vai para a universidade que fica
escondida numa montanha
numa cidade pequena na costa oeste do
canadá
essa universidade se chama com esta
significa busca jornada inglesa e
descontar é uma jornada chegar até lá
viveu
eu pedia carona que ia ter com o diretor
da faculdade tive que atravessar a
cidade é 100 ônibus subir a montanha
pessoal é doido é verão tem uns falência
do brasil não sei o que é isso então se
foi uma jornada inteira conseguir chegar
até essa adversidade ea quest porque vem
de quest on pergunta em inglês porque o
currículo deles é formatado todo em
torno de uma pergunta ao final do
segundo ano imagina isso o universitário
já escolhe uma pergunta que faz sentido
para ele aquilo que atiça muito a
curiosidade que ele quer descobrir
são perguntas de todas as formas desde
como as crianças aprendem línguas até
quais são as melhores políticas públicas
para países em desenvolvimento até
perguntas como o que é o paraíso quando
estava lá
uma das alunas dessa verdade que mostrou
campos lindo mas há sim uma estrutura
como de qualquer campus universitário e
eu tive que perguntar pra ela por que
você escolheu vim aqui aprender
escondida na montanha não foi atrás de
outra universidade que tem muito mais
renome muito mais conhecida mais
tradicional mais perto de casa e aluna
chegou ele respondeu não sei muito
frustrado com todas as respostas das
crianças
e aí ela depois chegou e falou pra mim
pra mim faz tanto sentido ataque que
seria estranho se não tivesse tanto
sentido tac
eu não sei se vocês têm a mesma sensação
que eu depois de uma viagem quando a
gente volta pra casa parece que está
tudo tão menor né
a nossa casa parece menor nosso trabalho
nossa rotina
assim existe também falta de engajamento
melhor formato de educação do mundo e
também existe a procura por sentido
escondido lá era uma montanha
eu acho que por brincar experimentar
tanto entre formato e sentido eu mudei a
minha carreira de engenheiro para
educador
tá eu não sou professor eu não estou ali
na sala de aula mas afinal de contas
educação acontece também entre quatro
paredes
e nessa minha jornada eu acabei entrando
uma instituição de ensino superior ea
gente entendeu que a revolução que a
gente queria
nesse nosso ensino é entender que o
sentido da educação é a gente conseguir
mudar transformar a comunidade onde a
gente está a equipe chechena educação
muda vida educação muda a história
então eu sei que é um clichê mas o
problema dessa frase é muito individual
uma reeducação da vida dessa pessoa
transforma a vida dessa pessoa e aqui
não aqui é muito mais sobre a comunidade
qual é a idéia deixe eu trabalho com a
idéia disse que a gente faz aqui nessa
universidade é a gente conseguir pegar
sabe aqueles cinco que sobreviveram no
funil da educação e consegui mostrar pra
eles que a formação deles
necessariamente passa por eles
conseguirem promoverem um atendimento
muito mais humano pra quem não tem
acesso hoje é conseguir mostrar pra eles
que a mudança que eles fazem uma
intervenção na cidade no espaço deles é
para tornar tudo mais inclusivo
inteligente é fazer com que aqueles
cinco que sobreviveram fui eu entendo
que o valor que lhe servem hoje é de um
objetivo de desenvolvimento que seja
mais sustentável é conseguir entender
que eles estão servindo todos aqueles
que de repente ficaram pelo funil ou que
nem chegaram a entrar nesse funil como
educador vamos ser mais prático é eu
consegui pegar um aluno que está ali na
formação na área de saúde dele e no
momento que tiver dentro de uma clínica
que ele entenda aqui é a parte prática
do curso de letras ali que ele tem que
fazer isso na disciplina e tem que
entender que no momento que tiver
naquele espaço
o aprendizado dele está comprometido com
a promoção ao acesso à saúde a quem não
tem um aluno de engenharia ele está ali
no curso fazendo só mais um projeto de
engenharia tecnologia porque engenharia
ele entender que naquele momento o
aprendizado dele está comprometido com a
resolução do problema local por meio de
uma tecnologia que vai servir a todos é
conseguir pegar um aluno do direito e
quando estiver fazendo o atendimento é
gratuito uma pessoa carente que aquilo
não é mais uma parte
de uma disciplina que está lá é nas
diretrizes curriculares nacionais
definidas pelo ministério da educação
não quando ele está fazendo esse
atendimento gratuito
o aprendizado dele está comprometido com
a promoção da justiça social
então é conseguir virar um pouco a chave
sai da coisa de estou fazendo isso
porque é o sistema não estou fazendo
porque isso tem um sentido é um
propósito muito maior
a educação é muito importante pra tá na
mão só dos educadores revolucionar a
educação não significa a gente pegar uma
sala de aula colocar todo mundo lá e
falar não agora ninguém vai sair daqui
revolucionar a educação não é a gente
comemorar
ao invés de 9 a gente consiga colocar 10
no ensino superior
se ainda assim só metade vai conseguir
formar e também não é a gente acreditar
que só quem tem diploma tem valor
revolucionar vai obrigar gente a criar
um outro papel a criar um outro olhar
com os ou com outro fifi o transe em
educação e entender que a gente tem que
valorizar a educação em todos os
formatos níveis
esse outro papel ele que vai trazer um
novo sentido para a sala de aula sala de
aula aquela de para tijolo carteira de
madeira estrutura de aço
então um outro papel é trazer um sentido
para essa sala de aula
obrigado
[Música]